when Darkness Falls over Kiev it falls
heavy street lights turned off household
saving power neighborhoods cycling
through blackouts after weeks of
sustained Russian strikes on the
country's energy grid
Ukraine's president using the darkness
in his nightly address
we are not afraid of Darkness the
darkest times for us are not the times
without light but those without freedom
during daytime life here can seem
deceptively normal but the recent
resumption of strikes on the city and
the mounting pressure on civilian
infrastructure is bringing the war ever
closer to home
in my apartment now I really have a weak
temperature like like most of ukrainians
but of course I'm worried I don't know
what we can expect in the future the
Russian campaign over the last couple of
weeks has been highly systematic
targeting not so much large power
generating facilities as small as
substations that transfer the
electricity to the rest of the grid
Soviet era and with parts that are hard
to replace restoring Supply is proving
difficult
it's a tactic that threatens homes
businesses and the digital space here at
lanet they provide internet access to
hundreds of thousands of customers their
servers automatically switch to a diesel
generator when the power is cut
the population usually gets information
alerts news explanation from the
government it's usually all done through
the internet people here are having to
improvise generators are in scarce
Supply disappointment for Natalia and
Alexander who are looking for extra
insulation as well but that was also
sold out
back home they say they're doing their
part to save power but almost everything
in their apartment runs on electricity
for all their positivity the pain of
this war intrudes all too easily
memories of the last winter when they
were under Russian occupation in a
nearby Village are informing their fears
of the coming one
they don't know how to fight a war so
they start bombing the civilian side
kids die many people with disabilities
already horrific things
outside the late Autumn night is closing
in and the temperature is dropping
across Kiev across Ukraine people are
bracing for a long difficult dark winter
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera Kiev